Oh Kevin is so nice to me yes she  BuzzFeed what's trending so tell me what  you're wearing tonight I'm wearing  Burberry from the house of Burberry so  when did you get up this morning to get  ready uh I got up at about 9:00 I had a  nice breakfast thought about playing  tennis but there just wasn't enough time  who did your hair I just you know just  it just happens yeah it's not a big deal  what about mani-pedi shows your  mani-pedi my what Danny man she is you  did you start smoking before you came  here today dieting for months getting  ready for this oh god no oh absolutely  not what about the Spanx you have any  Spanx on tonight what Thanks you know to  get it ready to get it tight so [ __ ]  up you guys just so good luck enjoy your  space thank you